[Musique]
bienvenue dans le paris los angeles et
sans troupes et des années 60 l'âge d'or
c'est l'histoire d'une rencontre qui va
changer le monde
entre un producteur est une actrice un
film tourné dans plus de 35 eu lieu
hommage aux artistes de l'époque des
beatles à brigitte bardot en passant par
françois truffaut des artistes qui
venaient des quatre coins du monde non
seulement français mais également en
anglais américains et qu'ils se
rendaient notamment dans ce petit
village à l'époque qui était un petit
port de pêcheurs maintenant devenu grand
saint tropez et donc c'est la bague on
trouve l'inspiration ils ont vraiment
réussi à changer ce monde qui marchait
sur la tête jeune réalisatrice de 27 ans
jena est à cannes pour distribuer son
film en france et à l'international au
sein du pavillon de l'europe la
chevrotine rencontre également des
directeurs de festivals pour la
promotion du long-métrage
l'âge d'or vient tout juste d'être
terminée et a été projeté au marché du
film et rendez vous c'est surtout les
directeurs de festivals et pas seulement
français avant en europe en asie en
afrique dans les amériques gréements
dans le monde entier les premiers
rendez-vous ont été extrêmement positifs
les premiers retours sur la projection
sont extrêmement positifs
donc on est vraiment très optimiste et
très fiers et c'est que le début parce
que je suis donc ici jusqu'à la fin du
marché du festival de cannes le marché
du film se clôturera le 23 mai deux
jours avant la fin du festival de cannes
en gros j'ai l'impression qu'à moitié du
temps
tout va mal et l'autre moitié du temps
c'est formidable
tu es déjà de la chanson été du tout ce
formidable
[Musique]